sus opiniones sobre el comunicado final
tras la cumbre del g20 éxito otro
encuentro que deja mucho que desear y
por qué
yo creo que la agenda del g20 abarcó
otros temas aparte del cambio climático
en términos del cambio climático creo
que ha sido insatisfactorio no el hecho
de determinar que no se van a emitir más
de 15 por ciento en los próximos años
sino que no determinar cuándo va a ser
la fecha precisa en que esto se va a
establecer y ahí hay una reticencia por
parte de china y de rusia muy clara a
que esto sean en 2050 como se estaba
planteando china en particular quiere
que esto se extienda al 2060 dado que
tiene su propia estrategia de desarrollo
que está basada en el consumo de ese
tipo de energía que está contaminando
pero además hay otros dos temas que me
parecen muy positivos que se ha avanzado
también con algunas dificultades la
primera es el impuesto a las compañías
transnacionales a las muy grandes
multinacionales de un 15 por ciento para
poder aportar a la recuperación
económica mundial y el segundo es el
tema de
cómo enfrentar la pandemia y
fundamentalmente orientado a impulsar la
distribución de vacunas e inclusive en
países en vías de
pero aquí también hay un punto que a mí
no me queda claro y es si la
reivindicación planteada por rusia y
apoyada por china ambas ausentes ambos
mandatarios han estado ausentes en la
reunión sobre el reconocimiento de la
vacuna sputnik 5 en realidad se ha dado
o no se ha dado no me queda claro de la
declaración sí y cuando se reconocen
todas las vacunas necesarias para
combatir con la pandemia sputnik que
está incluida entre esas vacunas